c'est tout le monde suit squeeze céiste
donc un petit message audio
cité pour des vins
l'abonné pour tout le chemin que tu as
fait jusqu'à jusqu'à présent toujours su
garder son originalité dans tes vidéos
c'est vraiment quelque chose de rare en
ce moment bah voilà un grand bravo à toi
et ciao
voilà pour le nom m'a demandé de faire
un petit message aux jo pour terme il a
beau n'être est plutôt une bonne idée
donc je fais ce crime a dit voilà je te
félicite marc poulin je penserais pas
que tu ailles va si vite
vingt mille abonnés bien jouer ou à lui
classé antoine et bien mon pote je
voulais juste dire un énorme bravo pour
tes vingt mille abonnés effectivement
c'est énorme et je pense que de manière
rien va tout le monde peut le dire quoi
tu l'aimés rita mohr tu as toujours tu
t'es toujours donné pour tes vidéos et
tu as toujours voulu satisfaire les
abonnés tous les abonnés quels qu'ils
soient
et donc voilà c'est pour ça je trouves
tu mérites tu mets est franchement tu
étais abonné donc voilà bravo à toi
[Musique]
alors faites mais je fais ce petit jeu
très castriste écouter lundi je pense
que notre pm du footing comme ça au
moins 200 millions de foyers sur ceux
encore en douter m'améliorer tous
webb à lucas je pense que tout va bien
et puis j'ai la tête dans le cul parce
que je voulais mais c'était juste pour
te dire un petit message et parce que
parce que tu déchire et tout et puis
quand on a décidé de faire ça donc je te
le faire en espèces de chant bizarre
soit juste pas gens produisent et ses
portes hier bravo à vos portes et 20
mille abonnés
vous allez un petit squeeze asséo artec
je te souhaite un bon courage et un
bravo pour ces vingt mille abonnés tu
verras c'est que le début d'une grande
période c'est absolument génial ce qui
t'arrive je suis content quand les faits
cette vidéo ensemble je suis content et
que ta chaîne prenne de l'ampleur et
marche comme elle marche parce que tu es
le mérite même si tu es complètement
chtarbé voilà bon courage pour la suite
et comme vous savez tous on va préparer
quelque chose d'énorme pour le deuxième
épisode une journée dans la peau noire
take this with salle et squeeze sept
sites où 76 juste un petit message
d'encouragement pour tes vingt mille
abonnés je te connais maintenant depuis
tes 6000 abonnés et je pense que tu as
fait vraiment beaucoup de chemin depuis
tant que tu continueras à nous faire
rire tu en feras encore donc bas au
plaisir de faire quelques projets avec
toi comme on en a parlé et puis et puis
bah félicitations pour tes vingt mille
eh bien mon cher lulu moussières l'uqam
ont eu hier squeeze et bah c'est avec un
grand honneur que monsieur sciatique te
souhaite un joyeux anniversaire non mais
bien bien joué porté 20 mille abonnés
c'est vraiment super fallait y super
cool pour toi je suis super heureux
tu es montée extrêmement vide espèce de
monticello port en déconnant tu es monté
très vite je suis super content pour toi
c'est vrai que c'est ce n'est que le
début
tu va encore monter la barre des 3
millions 4 millions facile invs lecerf
je te connais tu es assez fou pour ça
donc voilà en tout cas super
félicitations tu sais très bien ce que
je pense de toi je t'adore
et tout le monde tu adores ici présentes
et donc bah voilà en tout cas moi je te
fais plein de poutous pouteau partout et
puis bien jouer pour tes vingt mille
abonnés et puis là je prépare déjà mon
mon petit message pour tes 3 millions
d'abonnés qui vivons arriver d'ici deux
trois semaines donc il faut que je me
dépêche
voilà gros bisous sur la fesse gauche et
c'était cinétique et bailly montpetit
squeeze plus
bonsoir à tous c'était jean-pierre plus
connu sous le nom de zhang 6 donc voilà
petit cadeau pour toi squeeze tout
simplement parce que tu m'as lancé sur
youtube
je voulais prendre un peu la même voie
et tout simplement pour tous félicités
de tes vingt mille abonnés tu l'auras
compris vont dans tous les petits
messages avec des personnes que j'ai
réussi à contacter tout ça donc voilà
encore une fois félicitations continue
sur cette lancée change pas et et voilà
je te fais de gros bisous j'espère faire
un nouveau fun commence à y seraient
bonnes choses avec toi bientôt donc
voilà ko au bio
[Musique]